carrie underwood gave the performance of
a lifetime during her recent las vegas
show as she surprised fans by bringing
out her mom her mom carol for a very
special duet yeah and fan captured vid
the mother-daughter duo joined in
singing carrie's hit all-american girl
with carrie later taken to instagram to
share uh how her mom encouraged her to
audition for american idol carrie writes
in part this
if you want to go i'll take you these
might have been the most pivotal words
anyone has ever spoken to me i was busy
talking myself out of trying out for
american idol and my mom said these
words the rest is history tonight i got
to sing with her on stage in front of
the most incredible crowd in las vegas
yeah so sweet i remember her on american
idol and uh yeah she definitely doesn't
regret that audition well take a look
and we'll see back here next time
[Music]
[Applause]
are you ready
you have anything you want to say to
these fine people
i'm so happy you're here
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh